As I said,
being at the bank,
you're in an outpost where you see the
planet more clearly,
I think than in many other jobs almost
because of the design of the institution
and the nature of what it does.
And having been around,
uh,
many years at the high level,
I had I think more of a broad view than
most people have.
And when I was the European vice
president with Wolfenson,
we went all over the prime ministers in
the ministers and the g aids and the,
uh,
European summits and so forth.
And at some point I had this feeling,
which I then wrote about that in a way.
Um,
there was no pilot in the cockpit on
many global issues that they were these
un summits and this ga declarations and
so forth.
But that in true fact,
many of the big global problems like
global warming being one where not being
actively solved by the international
system as we know it.
And so one day I,
I did something I did every year,
which was to take a week off to write a
major speech.
I sat down and wrote a speech about this
question of why they were some two dozen
issues that were not being solved deeply
enough and fast enough and why that was
and what we could do to accelerate this
global problem solving that seems to be
so slow to come by.
And that speech worked out fine.
And then there was an extraordinary
moment where,
uh,
Chancellor Schroder who was then
chancellor of Germany as the World Bank
for a briefing,
which is remarkable actually,
yes,
to be briefed on poverty and development
issues.
And so we had a meeting with him in the
restaurant near Hanover on a Sunday.
I remember,
uh,
Wolfensohn Nick Stern,
who then wrote this famous climate
change report for the British government
later and myself and Chancellor Schroder
and two people.
And since I had organized the meeting,
I had kept one hour at the back of the
meeting for my ideas on global
governance and global issues.
And so Wolfensohn spoke for three or
four hours and poverty and development.
And then I started to talk about global
issues.
And Chancellor Schroder was very
interested,
and Jim Wolfensohn,
who was intrigued and interested as
well.
And in the evening when we had dinner
together after a successful day with
Chancellor Schroder,
I asked Wolfensohn what to do about it.
And he said,
these ideas go far beyond the World
Bank.
So write them up on under your own name.
And that led me to write the book,
which is a book that was critical of the
[inaudible] of the UN and so forth.
But somehow I got away with it a while
being in the institution as a sitting
vice president.
And that shows you one more time how a
open minded institution it was at the
time.
And I'm grateful for that.
And uh,
and then the book led into many speeches
and into a whole campaign on these
questions,
but that was the origin of it.